trust
few delights can equal the presence of
one whom we trust utterly george
mcdonald
how do you stand out against your
competition how do you get a steady
stream of new referrals how to get
people to happily pay more to work with
you
one word
trust you're in a tough spot you've got
a lot of competition and everyone is all
doing and saying the same things
everyone says they're the best everyone
shows great customer testimonials
everyone displays the media they've been
in right
and the end result is a confused
customer who doesn't know who to buy
from
so what can you do
you break through to them with trust
when people trust you then you become
the default person to work with suddenly
all the other factors including price
don't matter as much
they just come to you by default they
seek you out
so how do you become the trusted expert
answering this question might be one of
the most important things you do with
your business this year
number one share your story people buy
from people not companies people trust
people not companies so get personal
tell me why you started your business
what motivated you to do this why is it
so important to you what drives you to
keep going how does that make you feel
every day to wake up and help people
what are some of your goals who is
relying on you to make this business a
success
make me feel something
if i feel connected to you if i feel
like you really care if i feel your
passion for what you do then i'm going
to trust you and i'm going to buy from
you
you don't have to be a technical genius
to share your story start with the about
page on your website put a picture of
you your family your team on all your
marketing materials when you get brave
enough create a video of you sharing
your story
when i understand how important this
business is for you it makes my decision
so much easier to buy from you
caveat your business has to be important
to you and your passion about it beyond
just making money
so what is your story
number two stand for something
what is wrong with the world and how is
your company making a difference maybe
you're an organic farmer and believe
that people shouldn't be eating
processed foods maybe a computer repair
company and believe that technology
should make our lives easier not more
complicated
maybe you're a training company believe
that people deserve great service from
the suppliers they work with
if you're a boring company then people
won't care about you
if you take a stance on something and
are working to make the world a better
place then people trust you you'll also
get more ideal clients the clients who
will work best with you are the ones who
believe in the same things you do if you
don't stand for anything then it's a
crapshoot you hope that good clients
find out about you but when you stand
for something and make it known then the
clients who love that stance will come
and find you
they want to help you build a better
world
so what do you stand for
number three share even more i get so
many people who write in to me or meet
me at events and start off with i feel
like i know you
it's actually kind of strange for a
complete stranger to tell you that
but it's because in my newsletters in my
videos on my social channels at my
events i share myself
i tell people what i'm worried about i
tell people what i'm excited about i
tell people what i'm working on
if you're authentic and vulnerable and
just share
don't sell
share
you'll earn people's trust and they'll
want to buy from you you know those
people who you may hang out with every
now and then and they always have this
wall up
they're always concerned with how people
will judge them and so they never share
anything personal
you don't know what makes them tick or
what's good or bad in their lives
yeah don't be that person
you need to share
when you share you break down barriers
and build trust and trust leads to sales
so what can you share
but i'm shy i don't like being in the
spotlight
no problem i'm not asking you to go out
and become a master networker
i'm shy too believe it or not i'm not
the guy who goes up to people
introducing myself i don't strike up
conversations with the person next to me
on the airplane and it took me a while
years to get the courage to share my
story you don't have to be an outgoing
person to share what you're passionate
about and you can start by writing it
down for your website
start by writing down why you started
your business write it in your own words
and when you read it and feel proud you
feel excited you feel like you're doing
something important then put it up on
your website
but it's not about me i'm not an
egomaniac
again i felt the same way why should i
share my story it's not about me it's
about the products and services i'm
delivering it's about the customers
here's another lesson it took me years
to understand
people learn through your story
by sharing your story and your journey
it's not to pound your chest and say how
great you are it's to help inspire
others to action
you're here to help people and you want
them to make the right decisions your
story will help them to do that
so it's not about you it's about them
and the most effective way to reach them
is to tell your story believe